Das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Tribünengespräch. Ja, es ist wahr, ihr hört richtig, es gibt wieder ein Tribünengespräch. Kaum zu glauben, aber wahr und wir begrüßen euch herzlich und freuen uns, dass ihr uns jetzt hört. Und wenn ich wir sage, dann erfahrt ihr das zweite Unfassbare. Ich habe wieder meinen Frank an meiner Seite, den Co-Moderator, den ihr euch alle ständig wünscht, der Mann, der eine Stimme hat, wie ein warmes D-Dur gespielt von Bratschen. Hallo Frank!
Jetzt werde ich doch noch nervös. Hallo Max. Vielen Dank für die warmen Worte.
Ja, vollkommen zu Recht. Wie schön ist das, dass wir endlich mal wieder zusammen moderieren. Und nervös muss ich nicht sein, mein Lieber. Auch wenn es schon eine Weile her ist. Ja, ihr könnt dem Frank bei Twitter folgen als athelmi und ich bin bei Twitter der atgnetzer und wir haben, wie immer im Tribünengespräch, ein Thema, das die gesamte Sendung durchziehen soll und mit dem wir uns ausführlich beschäftigen. Und vielleicht hat sich der eine oder andere schon gefragt, was sucht jetzt Nobby Dickel in diesem Intro? Und das ist so ein bisschen der Grund, warum wir ihn reingeschnitten haben, liegt in unserem Thema begründet. Wer hätte es gedacht? Und das erklären wir euch am besten vielleicht, indem wir euch unseren Gast vorstellen. Wir freuen uns sehr, dass sie mit dabei ist. Giuseppina Dolle, eine Rasenfunk-Hörerin und Bayern-Fan und schon ganz lange im Fußball aktiv. Und warum das etwas Besonderes, erklären wir alles gleich. Aber erstmal sagen wir Hallo Pina, schön, dass du mit dabei bist.
Und das alles hört sich jetzt fantastisch an und spricht ja auch dafür, dass wenn man die richtigen Leute bei den Vereinen kannte, dann sind die einem da auch sehr offen und großzügig begegnet.
Es waren die ersten drei Jahre in München und die Fanclub-Leitung ist auch sehr personenbezogen. Und entsprechend haben die ihre Vereine häufiger gewechselt. Jetzt sind sie ganz enthusiastische Köln-Fans und sind da auch in der Köln-Szene sehr aktiv. Sind da auch mit den Fanbussen und Ultras und so was unterwegs. Also das, was ich in den 90er Jahren gemacht habe, machen die beiden jetzt. Und dadurch hat sich das zum einen dahin bewegt, dass wir eben jetzt ein allgemeiner, also vereinsübergreifender Fanclub sind, aber wir haben dann eben einfach auch andere Vereine kennengelernt. Also wir waren in Hannover, wir waren in Dortmund, wir waren in Schalke, wir waren in Hamburg, wir waren in München, Gladbach, Leverkusen. Und jetzt nochmal diese Verbindung zu den Kopfhörerplätzen. Wir hatten unser Fanclub-Treffen 1999 in Leverkusen und wir hatten als Gast Kurt Fossen dort, der damals ja Abteilungsleiter im Fußballbereich Barbaia Leverkusen war. Ja, und der hatte in Manchester erlebt, dass es dort irgendwie dieses Angebot für Blinde gibt, diese Reportagen. Und hat uns davon erzählt und hat dann so gesagt, ja, was würdet ihr denn halten, wenn wir Barbaia Leverkusen das mal machen? Na ja, und dann haben wir gesagt, ja super. Aber ehrlich gesagt, als er weg war, haben wir gedacht, hm, lass ihn reden. Da wird eh nichts passieren, wie viele wollen irgendwie was machen und, ne. Wurde dann mal kurz geredet und es passiert nichts, aber es passierte. Und Leverkusen, das war 99. Also wir hatten das Fettstreffen im Frühjahr. Und das erste Spiel war Leverkusen-Ulm in der Saison 99 2000. Und eines der Spiele drauf, das im Dezember Leverkusen unter Haching, das war mein erstes Spiel, wo ich dann hingefahren bin mit den Kopfhörerplätzen. Und Leverkusen hatte das ganz toll organisiert. Die haben nämlich als Reporter, jetzt mal zum Thema Schulung und Anspruch, die haben als Reporter den E-Jugend-Trainer gehabt. Burak. Und das witzige ist, der hat das jahrelang gemacht. Und jetzt, wenn ihr ihn sehen wollt, müsst ihr euch den Mannschaftsarzt von Bayer Leverkusen anregen. Unser Reporter ist jetzt Mannschaftsarzt bei Bayer Leverkusen. Du könnt die Karriere gehen.
Ich wollte ja sagen, das ist mal eine Karriere. Das ist ein lustiger Umweg vom E-Jugend-Trainer über Live-Reportage zum Mannschaftsarzt.
Genau.
Gibt's wohl auch kein zweites Mal. Aber da hat das Ganze angefangen, 99. Ja. Wir haben im Vorgespräch schon ein bisschen zu diesem Thema uns unterhalten und du hast dann gesagt, die große Explosion, die große Verbreitung für dieses Ding gab es dann zur Webmeisterschaft im eigenen Land.
Vielleicht vorher noch mal kurz. Nach Leverkusen ging es dann los in Hamburg, beim HSV und bei St. Pauli. Und dann kamen weitere dazu, aber die Organisation war sehr unterschiedlich, wie die Vereine das gemacht haben. Also Leverkusen, den E-Jugend-Trainer, da sieht man ja irgendwie schon, okay, das wollen wir nicht einfach nur so irgendeinen Fan machen lassen, sondern das ist schon gut, wenn das jemand macht, der auch von Taktik und sowas Ahnung hat, finde ich, ist daran zu erkennen. In Hamburg war es ganz interessant, also St. Pauli hat es über ein sehr engagiertes Fanprojekt gemacht und der HSV – und jetzt kommen wir nämlich zum Thema Qualität – beim HSV ist es so, dass es dort einen Studiengang – ich glaube, Sportwissenschaften heißt der – gibt und einer der Dozenten, Bruder Jürgen Trede, der hat sozusagen das genutzt, Studenten, die eben so in dem Bereich Sportjournalismus und sowas wollten, sozusagen da die Praxis zu bieten. Also die haben – der hat sozusagen das ausgearbeitet als Dozent, was muss für so eine Reportage wichtig sein, wo unterscheidet sie sich auch zur klassischen Radioreportage, was müssen so Reporter im Stadion, die vor Ort berichten können, wie muss die Sprache sein, was müssen Leute mitbringen und die haben das wirklich so gemacht, dass sie – also er dabei war natürlich und dass sie dann diese Reportagen aufgezeichnet haben und tatsächlich dann im Studium, also als Studieninhalt dann auch besprochen haben. Und dadurch ging das dann auch los, dass so im Laufe der Jahre auch dieses Know-how ja sich verbreitet hat, verbreitet wurde und dann irgendwann, als das dann Schule machte, ich nehme an, das war dann so Richtung 2006 irgendwann, dass dann auch die DFL mit auf den Zug gesprungen ist und es jetzt einmal im Jahr auch so, also seit Jahren schon ein jährliches Reporter-Treffen auch gibt, wo die Leute auch geschult werden, sich austauschen.
Das ist dieses Seminar, über das ich auf der Seehunde-Homepage auch gelesen habe.
Genau, was im Januar war.
Genau, zum neunten Mal, glaube ich, stand da.
Ganz genau.
Wohl auch dann in Verbindung mit der WM oder eben im Nachgang zu WM.
Genau, und wichtig ist Bruder auch immer und den Machern war es auch immer, dass Nutzer auch mit einbezogen werden. Weil die natürlich letztlich das Feedback geben müssen.
Aber wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, dann ist dieses Seminar auch, das es jetzt seit neun Jahren gibt, die einzige übergreifende Institution für das Ganze. Das heißt, jeder Verein kümmert sich oder eben das Fanprojekt vor Ort, dann selbst um seine Lösung. Es gibt da keinerlei zentrale Organisation dafür ansonsten, oder?
Nein, also sie haben jetzt so ein Kompetenzzentrum eingerichtet. Das ist noch nicht so lange. Das war ein ehemaliger Reporter von Leverkusen, der jetzt sozusagen dieses Kompetenzzentrum Blindenreportage so leitet. Aber ansonsten, es sind auch nicht immer die Fanprojekte. Also das ist ganz unterschiedlich, wie das in den einzelnen Vereinen gehandhabt wurde. Und um das nochmal mit der WM vorzuführen, irgendwann ging es natürlich auch darum, also wenn die WM schon in Deutschland ist, dann wäre es ja irgendwie nur recht und billig, wenn da natürlich Deutschland auch für blinde Fußballfans im Stadion Tickets anbietet mit diesem Reporter-Service. Und dann war das Voraussetzung, dass die WM-Stadien oder die Stadien, die eben WM-Stadien wurden, dass die Vereine das eben auch mit anbieten. Und einige Vereine, die sich eben vorher dafür nicht interessiert hatten oder auch geweigert hatten, die mussten dann halt. Und die haben es natürlich heute dann auch noch, zum Beispiel Kaiserslautern. Also Kaiserslautern war das so ein Ding, die hatten das vorher nicht. Und durch diese WM-Geschichte, ja, mussten sie und sind wahrscheinlich in der Richtung dann auch unterstützt worden. Das ist ja manchmal auch eine Frage, ja, was brauche ich und woher kriege ich dann die Anlage und so was alles. Mittlerweile ist es so, dass alle Erstliga-Stadien dieses Angebot haben, dass viele in der zweiten Liga und bis nach unten dritte Liga, teilweise auch weiter unten einzelne Vereine das anbieten. Und es ist heute auch nicht mehr so einfach, wie es noch in den ersten Jahren war, Karten zu bekommen.
Ja, viele…
Entschuldigung, wie viele Plätze gibt es denn da? Das würde mich noch interessieren. Also es sind ja Kopfhörerplätze und da sitzt jemand, der kommentiert. Und von welcher Menge reden wir da, auch wenn du sagst, es ist schwierig an Karten zu kommen?
Ja, das ist ganz unterschiedlich. Das handhaben auch die Vereine unterschiedlich. Also es gab Vereine, die haben… also ich kann mich erinnern, es gab mal… VfB Stuttgart hatte am Anfang nur fünf Plätze. Wie viele die jetzt haben, weiß ich nicht. Also beim HSV haben wir jetzt 30 Plätze, nachdem wir eine neue Anlage haben, die auch eine größere Reichweite fasst. In Köln sind es, glaube ich, auch 25 Plätze. In München weiß ich jetzt gar nicht genau, wie viele die haben.
Wir sind jetzt ohnehin ein bisschen quer in das ganze Thema eingestiegen. Vielleicht sollten wir das nochmal ein bisschen so zusammenfassend für die Zuhörer auch nochmal genauer darlegen, was ist denn so eine blinden Reportage im Stadion? Wie kann man sich das vorstellen? Wir haben gerade gesagt, es gibt Kopfhörerplätze. Das heißt, man kriegt eine Karte dafür. Du hast jetzt auch gerade gesagt, das ist unterschiedlich. Gehen wir mal davon aus, man hat jetzt eine Karte und kommt ins Stadion, da gibt es die Plätze. Da setzt man sich ran, da ist neben dem Stuhl einfach ein Kopfhörerstecker und man steckt den mitgebrachten Kopfhörer ein oder wie läuft das?
Das ist in Leverkusen auch so. Die haben das mit den Buchsen und den Kopfhörern. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie es jetzt nach Verlegung der Plätze immer noch haben, aber vorletzte Saison war es noch so. Die anderen Stadien machen das mit diesen Funkempfängern. Also es ist so, dass man, wenn man auf dem Platz sitzt, dann irgendwann so kurz vor 15-20 Minuten vor Spielbeginn kommt dann einer rum, entweder die Reporter oder eben irgendwelche anderen Helfer von dem Verein und verteilen die Kopfhörer. In manchen Stadien muss man sich das auch abholen, also Kopfhörer und Empfänger. Und das funktioniert mit Funktechnik, also nicht mit Kabel. Kabel ist wie gesagt nur in Leverkusen, ansonsten hat man eben Kopfhörer und so einen Empfänger, den man sich um den Hals hängen kann und wo man auch die Lautstärke verändern kann. Und da ist dann eben auf einem bestimmten Kanal, empfängt man das dann halt, der eben voreingestellt ist.
Wir haben im Vorfeld kurz einen Clip gehört, der auf einer Website zur Verfügung gestellt wurde, den wir glaube ich dann auch in den Show Notes verlinken. Das hört sich im Grunde, was man da hört, an wie eine normale Radioreportage, oder? Natürlich mit schwankender Qualität, abhängig vom Kommentator, vom Reporter. Aber im Grunde klingt das sehr ähnlich.
Ja, es klingt sehr ähnlich und für den Ausschnitt mag das auch stimmig sein. Aber der Radioreporter kann zwischendurch irgendwelche Geschichten erzählen, was er auch tut. Also ich fehl dir mal 90 Minuten Champions League mit zwei Reportern. Das ist nicht immer nur gut. Der Unterschied ist, du musst im Stadion absolut auf Ballhöhe bleiben. Du hast überhaupt keine Zeit, dich mit den Klamotten von Pep Guardiola zu beschäftigen oder mit einer Zusammenfassung von dem gerade Gesehenen, wenn wieder was auf dem Platz passiert. Weil im Stadion höre ich die Zuschauerreaktion, ich weiß sofort, dass was passiert. Und Anspruch ist wirklich, du musst das schildern, was der Sehende auch sieht. Das heißt, wichtig ist, wer hat den Ball und vor allem, wo ist er auch. Verortung ist so ein Schlagwort. Rechts am Strafraum und zieht jetzt rüber auf die linke Seite und da nimmt wer auch immer den Ball.
Also es ist noch ein bisschen mehr detailliert, das Geschehen auf dem Platz und nicht so sehr nur das Spielgeschehen, wie es bei einer Radioreportage ist.
Ja und vor allem auch, du musst auch reagieren, wenn plötzlich irgendwas ist, was die Zuschauer, also ich weiß nicht, wenn jetzt irgendwas in der Kurve oder sowas passiert. Also das erzählt der Radioreporter halt im Nachgang, aber du musst es in dem Moment, weil in dem Moment sieht man es ja. Ich muss wissen, was da passiert.
Um die Verknüpfung zum Gehörten direkt herzustellen.
Das heißt aber quasi, dass eine Radioreportage, die man ja zum Beispiel bei Sport 1 FM kann man ja jetzt auch Vollreportagen hören zu jedem Spiel, das ist ja einer der Gründe, warum es im Radio nicht mehr über 90 Minuten lang live gibt, das ist eine rechte Frage. Das ist quasi ein Plan B, aber das hat einfach nicht denselben Wert für jemanden, der das Spiel als Blinder erfahren möchte.
Ja, und ich merke auch, ich bin anspruchsvoller geworden, seit ich die guten Reporter im Stadion erlebe. Also gerade, wo du sagst, Sport 1, letztes Wochenende bin ich bald ausgeflippt, als ich hier ein Spiel gehört habe. Ich weiß jetzt, dass genau bei dem Dortmund-Bayerenspiel die erste Halbzeit war ja wirklich rassig und von irgendwie 1. bis 45. Minute war es wirklich auch eine tolle Reportage von dem Christian, keine Ahnung, was wie er hieß. In der zweiten Halbzeit gab es um die 50. 55. Minute eine Situation, da hat er 1000 andere Sachen erzählt. Ich hörte am Publikum, dass eigentlich auf dem Platz was passierte, aber er war nicht am Ball. Ich bin bald abgedreht, ich denke, was soll das denn, was interessiert denn, was letzte Woche vor zwei Jahren oder sonst was war? Der war einfach nicht auf Ballhöhe, obwohl was passiert ist.
Das heißt, eine Blindenreportage muss wesentlich deskriptiver sein und es geht auch weniger darum, rhetorische Stielblüten erwachsen zu lassen und Nebenschauplätze aufzumachen, sondern ganz destriptiv. Wo ist der Ball, was machen die Fans, was ist auf dem Spielfeld zu erkennen und das dann 90 Minuten?
Genau, und die wechseln sich auch ab, weil das kann einer nicht, die sind zu zweit. Und natürlich, wenn auch eine Verletzten-Situation – also ich habe jetzt ganz oft durch diese blinden Reportage und einfach auch viel mehr einen Einblick, was da jetzt gerade passiert, wenn da einer behandelt wird. Weil Radio oder Fernsehen oder so wird das ja nicht beschrieben. Man sieht es ja im Fernsehen und der Radioreporter sagt einfach, gut, das ist jetzt eine Unterbrechung. Klar, wenn du ein langweiliges Ballgeschiebe hast oder wenn irgendwie gar nichts passiert, dann hat ja auch der Reporter im Stadion mal die Möglichkeit, noch mal was zur Taktik zu sagen oder noch mal eine Szene zusammenzufassen. Aber dann muss er sagen, warum er jetzt gerade das machen kann. Also dann gibt es wirklich diesen Hinweis, es passiert jetzt wirklich nichts, deswegen kann ich gerade mal. Und was auch wichtig ist, ich meine, die Reporter lernen ja auch immer dazu und man ist ja auch nicht jeden Tag gleich gut. Deswegen sind sie ja auch immer so froh, wenn es dann Feedback gibt. Ich habe das jetzt beim Spiel HSV Gladbach erlebt. Da waren die Reporter am Anfang so ein bisschen im Stress, weil irgendwas mit Empfänger nicht in Ordnung war. Und dann sind sie relativ schnell so in dieses Spiel eingestiegen. Und was sie wirklich vergessen haben, und das habe ich dann in der Halbzeitpause gleich angemahnt, die haben nicht gesagt, von welcher Seite wer spielt. Und das brauche ich um im Kopf. Also ich möchte wissen, spielt Gladbach jetzt von links nach rechts auf die HSV-Kurve oder umgekehrt. Das haben die einfach vergessen. Aber das ist auch wichtig, so etwas zu sagen.
Damit dein Bild im Kopf quasi komplett ist.
Ja, und dich auch in die richtige Richtung gucken. Ich drehe auch dann mal meinen Kopf und bin dabei. Oder eine Situation, da ist der Reporter beim 3 zu 2. Also Gladbach hat ja kurz vor Schluss noch den Anschlusstreffer geschossen. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe in dem Moment erst mal gar nicht richtig gemerkt, dass da jetzt ein Tor gefallen ist, weil er mit der Stimme überhaupt nicht. Er hat das so, ja, so Tor. Und erst anhand der Gladbach-Reaktion und als der Stadionsprecher das dann gesagt hat, war mir wirklich klar, da ist ein Tor gefallen und das geht natürlich auch nicht. Also selbst wenn die Mannschaft dann verloren hat oder so, aber du kannst dich ja irgendwie nicht fünf Minuten später freuen. Andererseits gibt es natürlich auch lustige Situationen. Das war dann auch ein bisschen blöd gelaufen. Da war ich bei Wolfsburg gegen Bayern und dann hat Bayern ein Tor geschossen. Es war aber leider ein Abseitstor und ich war die Einzige, die da rumsprang und jubelte, weil der Reporter etwas länger braucht, um zu sagen, das war Abseits. Auch ein bisschen doof.
Ein bisschen ist gut. Wir haben im Vorgespräch auch kurz drüber gesprochen. Ich habe vor einigen Jahren mal einen Podcast gehört zu dem Thema Stadion, Blindenreportage im Stadion. Ich bringe leider nicht mehr zusammen, welcher es war und habe es auch im Vorfeld nicht geschafft, das zu recherchieren. Ich werde es noch weiter versuchen und das dann in den Shownotes ergänzen, wenn ich es herausgefunden habe. Allerdings kann ich mich erinnern, dass es damals um die Angebote in Hamburg ging und ich glaube, um beide, sowohl den HSV als auch um St. Pauli. Und ich meine, dass einer der beiden – und ich glaube, mich zu erinnern, dass es St. Pauli war – diese Reportagen teilweise auch im Netz anbietet hinterher. Gibt es solche Angebote generell? Machen das mehrere Clubs oder mehrere Stadionsender, das dann hinterher anzubieten? Das wäre mit Sicherheit auch mal für den einen oder anderen Hörer interessanter, mal reinzuhören.
Ich weiß es nur von St. Pauli. Da gab es am Anfang auch große Diskussionen, weil die Leute so ein bisschen Angst hatten, wenn sie das jetzt tatsächlich wieder für eine Gruppe von draußen auch machen, also jetzt quasi für Netz. Vergessen sie dann nicht, dass es wirklich darum geht, dann wirklich das tatsächlich für die Leute zu tun, die eben im Stadion sind, also für die Blinden. Es war so ein bisschen Angst, ob man dann wieder so in die Gefahr gerät, dass man doch von diesen Nebenschauplätzen und sowas dann erzählt, weil es eben für die Fans draußen ist. Aber das hat Pauli wohl ganz gut hingekriegt. Ich habe jetzt keine Beschwerden darüber gehört, dass die Reportage sich verändert hat. Kann ich mir bei dem Reporter auch nicht vorstellen, weil er das wirklich lebt.
Ist es aber tatsächlich nichts, was auf breiter Ebene angeboten wird?
Nein, also in Österreich ist es so. Die machen ja ein ganz anderes Konzept. Die haben ja sozusagen die Reportage im Stadion. Die Reporter im Stadion, die also die Stadionreportage machen, gleichzeitig auch den Fernsehbildschirm haben. Und das, was die sozusagen reportieren, kommt auf die Kopfhörerplätze im Stadion, aber auch gleichzeitig ins Radio in Österreich und eben für die Audiodeskriptionen bei der Fernsehübertragung von den Spielen. Das ist eine Geschichte, das läuft da wohl ganz gut. Ich kann es mir gar nicht vorstellen, weil es für mich drei völlig verschiedene Zielgruppen sind. Ja, und eben wirklich auch Stadion und Radio. Es ist nicht dasselbe.
Wahrscheinlich würde die Deskription noch eher mit Stadion zusammenpassen als die Radioreportage.
Ja, auch dich, weil du im Stadion ja manchmal Sachen siehst, die die Kamera gar nicht einfach einfängt. Wir haben im Moment die ersten Versuche. Es gibt ja jetzt die NDR-Spiele, also im Dritten die Regionalligaspiele mit norddeutscher Beteiligung, die der Norddeutsche Rundfunk überträgt. Die sind seit dieser Saison mit einer wirklichen Audiodeskription und das haben jetzt auch schon ein paar Mal Reporter aus unseren Stadien gemacht und für die ist das schon eine ganz schöne Umstellung, sozusagen die Reportage zu machen, nur vom Fernsehbild. Weil, ihr könnt das ja mal selber euch dran erinnern, was teilweise ja manchmal von der Kamera eingeblendet wird. Dann hast du ja wirklich nicht mehr das Spiel geschehen, sondern tatsächlich irgendwie eben nur Pep Guardiola oder was auch immer im Bild. Oder eben den auf der Tribüne sitzenden Pinguinen.
Okay, aber dann habe ich jetzt eine Vorstellung, wie es jetzt im Best-Case in einem Stadion aussieht und vielleicht könnte es ja auch in Zukunft die Veränderung geben. Es gibt ja jetzt in vielen Bundesligastadien schon WLAN. Meiner Meinung nach müsste es ja eigentlich auch gehen, das von diesen Reporterplätzen zu lösen, über die Apps, die die Vereine haben. Zum Beispiel, die Bayern haben eine eigene App, wo ich eigene Inhalte im Stadion WLAN sehen kann, Livestreams und so weiter. Eigentlich müsste man da mal den Impuls setzen, könnte da nicht auch die Blindenreportage hin streamen, dann ist es nämlich nicht mehr an ein Ticket-Kontingent gebunden, ob ich das verfolgen kann als Sehbehinderter. Wäre jetzt so mein erster Gedanke gewesen. Also das ist die Stadionsituation.
Wäre wahrscheinlich auch technisch eine Herausforderung wegen Zeitversatz. Das normale Streaming hat ja gerne das Latenzproblem. Das müsste man dann natürlich irgendwie so speziell lösen, dass da möglichst nicht mehr als eine halbe Sekunde oder Sekunde Versatz vorhanden ist.
Da hast du recht, ja. Okay, lassen wir diesen Einfall von mir, der dann doch nicht so glorreich war, wie ich dachte, lassen wir den mal hinten an. Aber das ist die Stadionsituation, das kann ich mir jetzt sehr gut vorstellen in so einem Best-Case-Szenario. Aber jetzt kannst du ja nicht immer in Stadion fahren. Man hat ja leider auch noch andere Dinge zu tun. Wie ist es denn? Geben dir Radio-Reportaten etwas oder auch Sport 1 FM? Ist das dann ein gutes Metadon, was den Stadionbesuch ersetzt? Oder wie konsumierst du von zu Hause aus Fußball am liebsten?
Ja, eigentlich schon so. Also Radio und wenn ich Spiel genauer hören will, das finde ich schon einen tollen Service, dass ich zum Beispiel in ganzer Länge oder die Bayern hören kann, wenn es eben nirgendswo anders läuft. Weil Radio – gut, während der Champions League und so – gestern hatten wir dann auch Dortmund an, hier über Internetradio ist das dann, glaube ich, oder Kabel. Also jedenfalls diese Event-Sender. Also WDR Event hatte das komplett übertragen. Das höre ich dann schon. Ansonsten ist es ja so, wenn wir hier NDR hören, dann ist es immer gut, wenn München gegen Norddeutsche Klub spielt. Weil es dann ein bisschen mehr an Berichterstattung gibt. Ja, also es gibt mir schon noch was. Es gibt natürlich auch Situats, wo muss ich auch ganz ehrlich sagen, da ziehe ich dann doch manchmal auch, wenn eben mehrere Sachen gleichzeitig angeboten werden, die Fernsehreportage vor. Ein Belaredi zum Beispiel, weil ich dann einfach die Stadionatmosphäre besser mitkriege, als wenn ich dann die Audiodeskription dazuhöre. Weil das haben sie technisch teilweise noch nicht so gut hingekriegt, dass dann die Atmosphäre richtig da ist. Und ich finde es schon auch immer noch interessant, ja, rauszuhören, ja, die Fangesänge oder was auch immer. Das kommt dann ja auch drauf an, in welcher Situation jetzt gerade auch das Fußballspiel läuft, guckt man sich mit wem zusammen oder... Was ganz schrecklich ist, das wäre dann wieder die Geschichte mit Zeitversetzung, wenn du dann eben Radio hörst und der andere guckt Fernsehen und ja, bei mir fällt der Elfmeter halt früher so und ich schreihe dann und dann kriege ich richtig Ärger beim Göttergarten im Nebenzimmer.
Ich stelle davor an, wie guckts Kai Gow, dann weiß er es schon, ich hatte schon...
Ja, aber dann hat man wenigstens noch eine gute Minute, um sich schon zu entschuldigen, bis dann auch die, die in der Kommt, wo man sich wieder konzentrieren muss. Ja, spannend, aber du bist ja dann noch viel, viel mehr vom Kommentator abhängig als sehende Fußballfans, wo es ja auch schon genügend gibt, die einen sterbenden Schwanen-Meme sobald Kommentator XY kommentiert. Und dann wird fröhlich getwittert, Stadionoption jetzt und zwar sofort mit vielen Ausrufezeichen. Wie ist denn das? Hast du noch die Möglichkeit, ein Spiel auch nochmal über andere Berichterstattungen nachzuarbeiten? Hast du manchmal das Gefühl, das wurde jetzt gar nicht so korrekt wiedergegeben? Du bist ja tatsächlich vollkommen von der Schilderung abhängig.
Ja, was ich schon spannend finde, das war jetzt gerade auch letztens bei dem HSV-Gladbach-Spiel wieder so im Stadion, das zu erleben, wo man dann so zwischendurch sich fragt, warum sind die Spiele eigentlich so viel wert bei diesem Geschiebe? Was ist das eigentlich? Und dann sieht man abends die Zusammenfassung, die ja nur ganz kurz ist und wo ja irgendwie klar sein muss, warum der HSV das irgendwie verdient gewonnen hat. Ich meine, das hat er auch verdient. Aber bei der Zusammenfassung habe ich gedacht, ich war bei einem anderen Spiel. Weil die das ganze Spielgeschehen so positiv dargestellt hat. Und ich dachte irgendwie so, hallo, das waren noch so viele Fehlpässe. Und da dachte ich irgendwie, ja, was ist das jetzt? Und habe mir dann damit einfach nur entschuldigen können, dass ich so gedacht habe, okay, die mussten irgendwie auf ihr 3-2 kommen und dass der HSV da halt gewonnen hat. Das muss irgendwie, ja. Aber ansonsten, ja, ich hatte es ja vorhin schon mal gesagt, also Nachberichterstattung, wenn ich irgendwie die Zeit finde, dann natürlich mit meinen Presse-Newslettern. Also die sind ja auch noch in meinem Postfach. Ja, und natürlich jetzt die Schlusskonferenz, ne? Ja, ist wirklich so. Also das ist schon so. Ich meine, ich interessiere mich jetzt nicht so für jeden Verein. Und verfolgt da auch nicht jedes Spiel so detailliert. Und das ist doch nochmal durch die Schlusskonferenz jetzt nochmal ein ganz anderes Erlebnis zum Teil auch. Also einfach nochmal mehr auch fernab wirklich auch von diesem Boulevard die Sachen dann auch mitzubekommen. Deswegen habe ich es auch in unseren Kreisen schon absolut empfohlen.
Das freut mich umso mehr. Und das ist ja jetzt die Situation im Bundesliga-Stadion. Und was würdest du sagen? Sind wir da in Deutschland auf einem guten Weg? Also wenn du sagst, bei vielen Zweitligisten gibt es auch schon und es ist geplant, dass es bald kommt, dann würde ich sagen, das hört sich jetzt gar nicht so schlecht an.
Ob wir jetzt mit den Kopfhörerplätzen auf einem guten Weg sind?
Genau.
Ja, würde ich schon sagen.
Und wo sind so die Bereiche, wo du sagst, gibt es noch Optimierungsmöglichkeiten?
Du hast vorhin gesagt, dass das aus England damals kam, als es in Leverkusen angefangen hat. Haben die das in England gesehen, bei Manchester United? Im Vergleich zu Deutschland, hast du Erfahrungen oder weißt du, wie das heute in anderen Ländern ist? Sind sie in England weiter als wir, wenn sie schon früher dran waren?
Das kann ich nicht sagen. Optimierungsbedarf will ich mal so sagen, aber nur als kurze Andeutung, weil ich da auch nicht näher einsteigen möchte, weil ich das auch eher nur so intern mitkriege. Ich finde es schwierig, also je mehr Leute da sozusagen am werkeln sind und je mehr es auch um Pöstchen geht, findet einfach auch teilweise keine gute Kommunikation statt. Da gibt es jetzt irgendwie so ein Kompetenzzentrum und es gab einen Tag zur Blindenreportage in Leverkusen. Fände ich auch ganz gut, wenn ihr das in den Showdowns auch den Link zur Aktion Menschseite dann noch mit rein stellt, weil man sich da wunderbar dieses Video zur Blindenreportage und zu diesem ganzen ansehen kann. Aber von diesem Blindenreportagetag ist im Vorhinein kaum berichtet worden unter den Reportern. Ich finde zum Beispiel gerade der Bruder aus Hamburg, der das ja mit angeschoben hat, auch diese ganzen Qualitätsgeschichten und so, da wird er, finde ich zum Teil, einfach sehr stiefmütterlich behandelt. Ich finde einfach, da muss man so ein bisschen gucken, dass da Kommunikationswege auch gut laufen, wie überall, wo Menschen zusammenarbeiten.
Was gibt es so für Seiten, die du empfehlen kannst, sowohl für Blinde als auch für andere, die sich einfach fürs Thema interessieren, wo man sich dann im Internet gut informieren kann?
Ja, also aufgebaut wird jetzt diese Seite Blindenreportage. Also wie gesagt, die ist im Aufbau, aber das soll sozusagen auch dahin führen, dass man irgendwann, so wie man früher das Tor des Monats, irgendwie den O-Ton des Monats wählen kann. Das ist vielleicht auch eine ganz witzige Geschichte. Dann natürlich Fanclub Seehunde, also unsere Fanclub-Seite. Weil man dort auch die Information finden kann, erstens, in welchen Stadien gibt es Plätze. Und wir versuchen auch, das immer aktuell zu halten, wie man an diese Tickets kommt, also die entsprechenden Kontakte und so. Übrigens, Würzburg-Hickers startet jetzt auch damit. Wollte ich nur mal so sagen. Ich wollte auch sagen, dem Frank kennen. Ach so, dem Frank.
Ich dachte immer, wenn ich Frank höre, dann fühle ich mich gleich angesprochen und höre für die letzten zwei Buchstaben weg. Stimmt, das habe ich auf der Seehunde-Fanclub-Seite vorhin gesehen. Das ist auch ganz neu.
Und es gibt, um das nochmal zu ergänzen, es gibt auch ein paar Bundesligisten, das möchte ich ja nicht verschweigen, die auch eigene blinden Fanclubs haben. Borussia Dortmund hat einen eigenen Fanclub, Blind Date. Es gibt bei Berlin die Seebären, die sich auch im Fußballbereich und mittlerweile auch noch in anderen Sportarten engagieren.
Das heißt, wenn das jetzt andere Seebehinderte hören, die vielleicht noch nicht den Sprung in Stadion zum Beispiel geschafft haben, dann wären das so die ersten Adressen, die sie an-surfen könnten und wo sie sich informieren können und miteinander verbinden.
Und auch auf der Seite der BBRG, das ist ja die Bundesbehindertenarbeitsgemeinschaft. Die haben auch eine eigene Seite. Aber gerade unsere Seite jetzt von Seehunden, wirklich diese Auflistung mit den Stadion, das ist schon irgendwie ein schneller Zugriff. Also da sieht man dann auch, das es sogar in Erfurt und bei Holstein-Kiel und Braunschweig, also auch wirklich bei kleinen Vereinen solche Angebote gibt. Vielleicht ist es da auch ein bisschen einfacher mit den Karten, wenn man da in der Nähe auch dann wohnt und sich für seinen Ortsverein sozusagen interessiert.
Also packen wir definitiv alles in die Shownotes. Die Links sind alle zu finden. Gibt es denn eigentlich etwas, was auch andere Fußballfans noch besser machen können, wo man Sehbehinderte unterstützen kann? Oder würdest du sagen, da gibt es jetzt gar nicht so viele Berührungspunkte? Ich kann mir das immer noch gar nicht so wirklich vorstellen, wie das ist, nicht sehenden Auges sich durch diese Massen an Menschen zu schieben. Gibt es da irgendwelche Dinge, die für euch wichtig sind, auf die ich vielleicht gar nicht jetzt gekommen wäre?
Naja, ich sage jetzt mal ganz ketzerisch. Jeder, der sich mit Bengalos oder mit irgendwelchen Geschichten im Stadion daneben benimmt, der bringt Leute in Gefahr. Und der bringt natürlich auch Behinderte in Gefahr. Ich sage mal, die Situation, eine Geschichte in Leverkusen zum Beispiel, die haben die Plätze vorher, das fand ich wunderbar, die hatten die Kopfhörerplätze direkt neben dem Stehblock der Gästefans. Es war für mich immer ein wundervolles Spiel in Leverkusen gegen Bayern, weil ich direkt neben den Gesängen saß. Die haben die Plätze jetzt auf die andere Seite des Tores, also nach rechts verlegt, nachdem nicht nur der Reporter, sondern eben auch Leute auf unseren Plätzen dann mit vollem Bier und Urinbechern und sonst was von den Kölnern beworfen wurden. Also das war einfach zu gefährlich, die Plätze in dieser Ecke zu lassen. Unsere Fanclub-Leitung – ich hatte das ja vorhin schon angesprochen – Regina und Nina sind in Köln unterwegs und haben dort Kontakte zum Fanprojekt und auch zu den Ultras und sagen eben auch, sie finden das auch ganz wichtig, auch denen einfach auch so bewusst zu machen. Es gibt auch Leute, die eben da nicht so schnell wegrennen oder was auch immer können, wenn Situationen einfach sind. Insgesamt würde ich mir wünschen, das ist aber jetzt nicht nur bezogen auf Fußballfans, sondern das ist ja so generell einfach offen zu sein und wenn man eher unsicher ist, nicht irgendwie die Augen schließen und sich an die Seite stellen und versuchen, vorbei zu schleichen, sondern eher irgendwie zu verbalisieren. Also ich finde das ganz oft schwierig im Kontakt mit Sehenden. Ich kann das immer erklären. Ich weiß, warum Sehende sich so verhalten, aber es macht es mir eben noch schwieriger, wenn Leute eben einfach versuchen, sich um die Situation drumherum zu lavieren. Also leise zur Seite zu gehen und ich gehe dann vielleicht mit meinem Stock trotzdem in die Richtung, wo die Leute gerade stehen. Also eine Ansprache, Achtung, hier stehe ich oder kannst du schlecht gucken oder irgendwie. Also lieber offen verbalisieren als irgendwie zu meinen, ich habe da jetzt Angst vor. Finde ich sehr schwierig. Und die Situation, sage ich jetzt mal, vor einem Eingang zur S-Bahn nach dem Spiel, wo man eben zerquetscht und zerdrückt wird. Die ist ja nun, also muss ich euch nicht sagen, die ist ja für alle schwierig. Und wenn du da ein kleines Kind dabei hast, ist es irgendwie auch schwierig. Und wenn du dann eben so Besoffene dabei hast, die nicht mehr so genau wissen, was sie tun oder einfach nur gut drauf sind und jetzt wollen wir mal von hinten oh, jetzt springen wir da mal rein und schubsen so ein bisschen. Also da gab es jetzt auch so zwei, drei Situationen, wo ich so gedacht habe, boah, muss ich mir sowas irgendwie noch so antun? Weil ich wirklich das Gefühl hatte, ja, ich wäre zerquetscht, obwohl mein Begleiter groß ist und versucht, so einen Raum zu schaffen. Aber da muss ich auch sagen, es gibt immer, und das möchte ich auch an dieser Stelle ganz deutlich sagen, ich habe immer in diesen, ja, angstbesetzten Situationen immer wieder auch erlebt, dass andere Leute wahrnehmen, dass ich mit meinem Blindenstock, dass ich da bin, und versuchen, die anderen, ja, also mich quasi zu schützen. Also, wildfremde Leute. Also, die dann versuchen, die entweder sogar sagen, ey, pass doch mal auf, oder die wirklich versuchen, mit ihrem Arm irgendwie diesen Freiraum so zu schaffen. Und das finde ich schon auch sehr schön so.
Ja, es reduziert sich dann letztlich dann doch wieder einfach auf gesunden Menschenverstand und Respekt im Umgang miteinander, wenn man ehrlich ist.
Ganz genau.
Klar, und der fehlt halt natürlich oft bei vielen in solchen Situationen, eben wie du sagst, betrunken oder im Siegesrausch oder wie auch immer. Da wäre einfach ein bisschen mehr Respekt wahrscheinlich insgesamt angebracht. Und speziell natürlich Menschen gegenüber, die dann zusätzlich eingeschränkt sind.
Ja, aber grundsätzlich nochmal, ich habe es ja vorhin auch schon mal gesagt, durch diese vielen Erlebnisse im Fußball und so habe ich einfach, durch dieses gemeinsame Interesse, meine Offenheit, aber eben wirklich auch dieses Ja, da ist man dann zusammen im Stehblock, auf der gleichen Wellenlänge habe ich wirklich einfach auch viele tolle Kontakte kennengelernt. Teilweise sind sie noch, teilweise natürlich nicht mehr, weil sich da die Lebenswege einfach verändern, aber da habe ich viel, viel Positives auch draus gezogen.
Ja gut, und du hast Dinge erlebt, meine Güte. Norwich City gegen Nottingham Forest im September 87, da lecken sich andere die Finger nach. Also schon erstaunlich, was man dann auch wirklich, wenn man einfach begeistert für die Sache ist und viele Dinge auf sich nimmt, hast du ja auch thematisiert, dann kann man schon auch wirklich tolle Sachen erleben und das dann auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise. Wie ist es denn jetzt, wenn du heute so im Amateurfußball unterwegs bist? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, so ganz banale Frage, aber wenn neben mir jemand stehen würde, der Sehbegleitung ist und der dann die ganze Zeit das Spiel kommentiert und das dann vielleicht nur so mittelgut macht, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das aushalten könnte. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich dann nicht entweder sagen würde, kannst ich bitte machen, oder ob ich den Platz wechseln würde. Ist dir sowas schon mal passiert? Fühlen sich die Leute vielleicht auch manchmal gestört?
Ja, so ein- zweimal hat das schon. Also ich habe das schon mal erlebt, dass jemand mal verbessert wurde. Aber na gut, ich meine, ich sehe das ja nicht, ob einer dann weggeht. Ich meine, wenn du weggehst, bist du weg. Du sagst ja jetzt nicht, das nervt mich, ich gehe jetzt weg, sondern du gehst dann halt.
Ja klar, würde ich ja auch nicht tun. Ich meine, das ist ja eine Form.
Nein, aber ich meine, wenn das so ist, wenn sich jemand gestört fühlt. Was ganz witzig ist, also weil du jetzt den Amateurfußball ansprichst, ich hatte das ja vorhin auch schon angedeutet, ich bin, also 2006 war so ein Jahr, da habe ich irgendwie so- war ich irgendwann mal satt, weil ich eigentlich alles erlebt habe, was man erleben konnte. Ich bin mit Bayern Meister geworden und war sozusagen beim letzten Heimspiel da. Ich war das erste und einzige Mal beim Pokalspiel in Berlin und habe da den Sieg miterlebt. Ich bin Weltmeister geworden, weil ich bin großer Italien-Fan. Das war, ich habe Weltmeisterschaftsspiele erlebt mit diesen Blindenkarten. Also ich war insgesamt sechs WM-Spielen hier in Deutschland in Stadien. Ich war einfach, ja, ich war irgendwie so satt. Also ich hatte dann wirklich so ein halbes Jahr, wo ich irgendwie Bundesliga-Fußball nur so am Rande. Das war einfach, irgendwann ist das mal gut. Man kann man irgendwie nicht mehr erreichen. Und durch einen Begleiter, also ich habe ja mit meinen WM-Spielen fünf verschiedene Männer glücklich gemacht, die mich sozusagen zum Spielen begleiten durften, bin ich eben über einen. Der hat selber hier im Kreis Pinneberg in einer Mannschaft auf Kreisklasse oder Kreisligaebene gespielt. Kreisklasse war es glaube ich damals. Bin ich dann halt das erste Mal, weil ich so gedacht habe, oh, dann gehe ich mal dahin, wo der spielt, bin ich also zum Kreisklassen-Fußball gegangen. Und das habe ich, ja ich glaube, das war so eine Zeit vier, fünf Jahre sind wir, mein Mann und ich, regelmäßig hingegangen. Und das war schon nochmal eine ganz andere Situation. Zum Eilen, weil man die Spieler, die Mannschaft und die Funktionäre und so eben kannte und sich teilweise selbst engagiert hat, also ich habe dann auch für den Verkauf Kuchen gebacken und sowas alles. Man war direkt am Spielfeldrand, also hinter der Stange, also direkt am Spielfeld. Da gab es dann so Situationen, dass mal so eine Geschichte war, dass mein Mann irgendwie meinte abseits und der Schiri sich umdrehte und sagte, das entscheide ich. Dem haben wir dann erklärt, warum da diese Erklärungen kommen. Das Spiel ist nicht so klasse, dass da jemand immer irgendwas sagte. Und lustig war, dass – ja, die Reportage war wohl gut genug, dass ich meistens immer zur richtigen Zeit den entsprechenden Namen unserer Mannschaft, also des Spielers, gerufen habe. Die waren manchmal etwas irritiert, weil sie eigentlich wussten, ich bin blind und konnten überhaupt nicht verstehen, warum ich dann plötzlich den entsprechenden richtigen Ruf loswerden konnte. Ja, ganz genau, das war wirklich so. Das war an manchen ein bisschen irritiert. Das haben die jetzt im Nachhinein ein paar Leute auch nochmal so gesagt, so in Gesprächen. Und ich kann es nicht erklären, weil es ist einfach so, ich kann irgendwie ein Spiel, wie sagt man, ich kann irgendwie ein Spiel lesen. Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich oft einfach das richtige Gefühl für die Dinge habe, die da irgendwie passieren oder noch kommen. Was ich dann aber nicht näher beschreiben kann. Also durch das, was ich höre, und das ist natürlich bei so einer Kreisliga-Geschichte, wo du halt direkt dastehst und dann auch die Spielerreaktion hörst und Gespräche von einer Bank und so. Da ist das ja nochmal verschärfter, was man da einfach so mitnehmen kann, wenn man eben nicht durchs Visuelle abgelenkt ist. Ich habe eine Situation mal erlebt. Der Oli Fritsch ist ja mittlerweile, hatte ich ja vorhin erwähnt, Freistoß. Den Pressenspiegel hat er ja sozusagen initiiert. Der ist mittlerweile bei Zeit Online. Wir hatten zwischendurch öfter mal Mailkontakt, viele Jahre. Er war mal Trainer hier in Hamburg bei SV Blankenese. Da hatte ich natürlich den Anspruch, dass ich ihn ja gerne auch mal persönlich treffen wollte und ihn als Trainer auch mal erleben wollte. Ich bin dann zu einem Pokalspiel gegangen. Da hat Blankenese gegen Tornetsch hier bei mir im Kreis gespielt. Blankenese war, glaube ich, von der Position der Liga sogar eine höher und hat aber dieses Pokalspiel verloren. Da waren auch ganz viele Sachen mit roter Karte. Jedenfalls habe ich dann Olli am nächsten Tag meinen Eindruck geschrieben und habe auch ein paar Sachen geschrieben, nach Spielern gefragt. Ich habe ein paar Sachen, die ich beobachtet hatte, geschrieben. Dann hat er nur zurückgeschrieben, dass er mir mal meine Spiele anzeigen darf. Das wäre unglaublich, was ich da treffend formuliert habe. Da habe ich nur so gedacht, ich habe doch ein bisschen Ahnung.
Das heißt, es ist gar keine Beleidigung, wenn Lobby Dickel im Fanradio schreit, Schiri, du Blinder. Eigentlich lobt er damit, seine Fähigkeiten das Spiel zu lesen.
Ja, vielleicht die Schiri ich auch mal so verstehe. Vielleicht noch mal zum Auslandsfußball. Ich habe mir zumindest einen Traum auch erfüllt. Du hattest ja vorhin gesagt, diese Geschichte in England, das war ja, ich sage jetzt mal, purer netter Zufall, wo ich jetzt in meiner Biografie sagen kann, ich war auch mal in England beim Fußball. Aber mein großer Traum war ja auch mal nach Italien zum Fußball. Und die Nationalmannschaft von Italien habe ich schon mehrfach gesehen, aber eben immer nur in Deutschland. Länderspiel von Italien in Italien habe ich leider noch nicht geschafft. Aber ich habe mir mein Traum erfüllt. Ich war einmal in Turin. Und zwar war ich, ich glaube, 2014 im März, also es war zumindest ein Ligaspiel, die Event des Turin gegen AC Florenz. Und das war sonntagsmittags. Da waren wir also von freitags bis montags in Turin. Und dienstagsmorgens sind wir dann, also wir sind montags hier nach Hamburg zurückgekommen und sind dann am Dienstag zum Champions League-Spiel nach München gefahren.
Das ist nicht so schlecht. Und durch die Ohren einer Blinden, was sind die Unterschiede?
Also was mich in Turin schon beeindruckt hat, also erstmal ist es ja sehr schwierig an Karten zu kommen. Deswegen habe ich das Ganze über ein Reisebüro organisieren lassen von Flug und Hotel, also quasi mit diesen Tickets, die dann im Hotel für uns zurückgelegt waren. Und die Karten sind ja personalisiert. Und ich konnte mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, gut man kennt es von der WM, aber jetzt so beim normalen Liga-Alltag, ich konnte mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, wie das dann an den Eingängen ist. Ich dachte, das muss ja ewig lange dauern. So, jetzt war ja erstmal die Besonderheit, dass das ein Sonntagsmittagsspiel ist, um halb eins war das. Wir sind von unserem Hotel aus mit einem normalen Stadtbus zum Stadion gefahren. Der kam an und war schon rappelvoll. Vielleicht lag es an der Mittagszeit, aber wenn ich mal vergleiche, so eine volle Busfahrt, also auch schon auf dem Hinweg hier, und das, was ich dort erlebt habe, muss ich sagen, wow, was diszipliniert. Also es war richtig ruhig, es wurde auch nicht gesungen oder so, aber es war auch nicht so dieses Sich-Anbrüllen oder dieses Geschupse. Also schon als wir einstiegen, standen wir schon im Eingangsbereich einfach sehr Sardin-mäßig und dann hat Papa seinen Sohn auf den Schoß genommen und dann konnte ich mich damit hinsetzen. Dann sind wir sogar ins Gespräch gekommen auf Englisch und der Sohn war großer Vidal-Fan und so. Dann sind wir an das Stadion gekommen und dann war er so aufgebaut. Klar gab es auch so ein paar Essensboden, aber irgendwie auch noch so ein Kinderkarussell oder sowas. Dann kamen wir da hin und so schnell war ich noch nie im deutschen Stadion wie dort. Ich habe gar keine Ahnung. Keine riesen Schlangen. Die haben auf den Personalausweis auf die Karte geguckt und schwups waren wir drin. Dann fand ich die Preise interessant. Ich meine, wenn du das Geld zusammenrechnest, war es natürlich genauso wie hier, aber anders. Der Schwerpunkt war anders. Wasser war total günstig, ein großes Wasser. Hier zahlts ja auch 4, 50 Euro oder so. Aber da war das erschwinglich. Dafür war die Wurst entsprechend teuer und auch nicht lecker. Dann war es interessant mit den Toiletten. Das hätte ich jetzt bei Italien gar nicht erwartet. Ich glaube, in der Halbzeit muss ich aufs Klo. Es ist ja überall voll. Dann bin ich da auf die Frauentoilette und komme raus und sage nur zu meinem Mann, da waren Männer. Das ist irgendwie komisch. Da waren Männer. Dann hat er das wirklich bestätigt. Weil bei den Männern so eine riesen Schlange war, sind die Männer da mit auf die Frauentoiletten. Das habe ich zumindest hier in Deutschland noch nicht erlebt. Ich hätte es gerade von Italien auch nicht erwartet. Dass Männer da auf die Frauentoiletten gehen, das fand ich ziemlich lustig.
Und wie war es dann so vom Support während des Spiels? Was ist denn jetzt dann eigentlich für dich, jetzt nur aus deiner Perspektive gesprochen, besser? Spielbezogener Support, also wäre für dich eigentlich ein Geisterspiel perfekt, weil man da richtig den Ball auch manchmal hört. Manchmal hört man, was die Spieler rufen. Oder wie hättest du es am liebsten?
Da sagst du was Beides. Ich hätte gerne mal ein Geisterspiel, aber wo dann auch jemand neben mir steht, der mir dann auch sagen kann, wen die da rufen hören. Das wäre schon mal interessant. Aber ansonsten natürlich ist es mit Support-Klasse. Also und zwar spielbezogener Support. Also ich möchte irgendwie nicht 0 zu 4 mit meiner Mannschaft zurückliegen und dann singen meine Fans dann immer noch und feiern sich selbst. Das finde ich dann irgendwie auch, weiß ich nicht, nicht angemessen.
Macht das für dich auch schwieriger, ein Spiel zu lesen in dem Sinne, dass halt heutzutage, also ich kenn's ja von vielen Bayernspielen, 85. Minute gegen alle Stadionverbote und zwar ganz egal, wie steht. 0 zu 8 oder 8 zu 0 ist egal. Kannst du trotzdem an der Art und Weise wie gerufen wird, noch Veränderungen wahrnehmen oder ist das für dich auch schwierig? Also ich blende das ehrlich gesagt dann manchmal aus. Also wenn ich nicht mitsinge, was bei manchen einer Art von Fangesängen vorkommt, alles was so mit anderen Mannschaften zu tun hat, das interessiert mich in dem Moment nicht, dann bin ich voll aufs Spiel fokussiert und dann kriege ich manchmal auch gar nicht mehr mit, dass die jetzt das schon seit drei Minuten singen und steigt dann erst später wieder ein, wenn sie was singen, was sich auf meine Mannschaft bezieht, wo ich mitsinge. Geht dir das auch so oder?
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass es dann schwieriger wird. Man hat natürlich immer noch Leute im Stadion, die erschrocken reagieren, wenn der Ball fast ins eigene Tor fällt. So ein bisschen kriegt man es dann doch noch mit. Vielleicht höre ich auch mehr Nuancen, aber grundsätzlich macht es das dann schon schwieriger. Dein zweiter Teil – da bin ich dann nicht so ganz bei dir – finde dann kreative Lieder gegen die anderen Vereine dann schon auch mal ganz nett. Also ich habe dann in Leverkusen schon mitgesogen, ihr werdet nie Deutscher Meister oder unter Haching angefeuert als Bayern-Fan. Das muss man dann in Leverkusen halt mal machen.
Ja, ich beziehe mich da ehrlich gesagt. Also in Freiburg, ich habe ja an Freiburg studiert und war da viel im Stadion. Da ist jetzt auch nicht alles golden, aber da gab es schon manchmal. Also es ist kein Zufall, dass es aus Freiburg kam mit dem Idrissou, spielt Champions League auf der PS3. Aber ehrlich gesagt langweilt mich ein BVB-Huansöhne oder ein Tod und Hass, dem TSV oder auch dem FCN. Das ist mir doch vollkommen egal, wenn wir gerade irgendwie zuhause gegen Werder spielen.
Ja, das ist richtig. Ja, das ist natürlich richtig. Ja, macht es schwieriger. Naja, und der Support in Italien. Also da muss ich sagen, wir haben viele Sachen leider natürlich auch erst wegen unserer fehlenden Sprachkenntnisse erst im Nachhinein erfahren. Da sind auch gerade bei dem Spiel Turin und Florenz nicht so tolle Sachen gelaufen. Also so rassistische Sachen sind da gelaufen, beziehungsweise die Florenz-Fans hatten irgendwie dann auch so ein Plakat mit zwei Spielern, Cillini und irgend wem anderen, da irgendwie so bezogen auf diese Juwel-Fans, die da bei dem Heisel-Drama ums Leben gekommen sind. Also ganz unschöne Sachen und Affengeräusche und so was alles. Und die Turina hatten an dem Tag irgendwie noch so eine Fan-Freundschaft, die sich gejährt hat, gefeiert, auch mit irgendeiner schwierigen Gruppe da aus Holland. Das haben wir leider erst im Nachhinein erfahren, weil wir eine Nachbarin haben, die Italienisch spricht und die uns dann die entsprechenden Zeitungsartikeln, die danach kamen, auch vorgelesen hat. Mein Mann hat die Zeitung dann halt im Flugzeug gesehen mit dem entsprechenden Bild. Und dann haben wir die halt mitgenommen und uns das hier übersetzen lassen. Und dadurch haben wir halt mitgekriegt, dass da schon so ein paar Sachen waren. Und der eine Blog, der Auswärtsblog, der neben uns war, der war auch nicht ganz ausverkauft. Also da war wohl auch schon irgendwie eine Blogsperre gewesen. Ansonsten, ja, war es auch so ein bisschen, wie ich das vorhin schon so vom Event-Tempel hier gesagt habe. Es war natürlich ein bisschen Support, aber es war ganz oft auch irgendwie wenig. Also, ja, wie man ja manchmal auch so den Bayern-Fans nachsagt, das wären irgendwie, naja, das sind dann halt so die Erfolgsfans oder so, wo irgendwie nicht mehr so viel an Stimmung und so rüberkommt. Und das war bei Juve auch so ein bisschen. Toll war die Mannschaftsaufstellung, toll war dieses Lied, was sie immer spielen. Das ist ja nun jetzt kein richtig schnelles, sondern eher so ein langsam getragenes. Aber das war einfach ganz toll, wie sie das alle mitsingen. Also auch die Leute drumrum dann die Texte mitsingen und so. Also was auch wieder gigantisch ist, ich habe Tonaufnahmen gemacht. Also ich habe ein ganz tolles Mikro dabei gehabt und eben natürlich nicht das ganze Spiel aufgenommen, sondern eben die Mannschaftsaufstellung und das Lied und dann immer so Passagen im Spiel. So kurz vor der Halbzeit und dann mal hier zehn Minuten und mal hier zehn Minuten. Ja und das Spiel ging eins zu null für Juve aus und ich habe das Tor drauf. Ist das nicht göttlich?
Ja, sehr gut.
Mit der Reportage meines Mannes und ja, dass eben das Tor fällt. Und was meinem Mann halt aufgefallen ist, das ist natürlich jetzt nur so ein Einzel-Eindruck, aber wir hatten uns in der Halbzeit dann halt so an die Bande gestellt und da hat ein Ordner uns sofort so zurückgepfiffen, also weg von der Bande. Das haben wir dann natürlich auch gemacht und dann hat mein Mann gesehen, auch so ein Turid-Fan hatte sich an die Bande gestellt und hat auch sofort, als der Ordner was sagte, den Rückzieher gemacht. Und hier, finde ich, erlebt man ja ganz oft, dass dann erst mal diskutiert wird, ey Alter, was willst du und so. Und da sagt man so, das wäre jetzt beim HSV oder so ganz anders gewesen. Also das fand er gut, aber es war eine Momentaufnahme. Also da kann ich jetzt überhaupt nichts verallgemeinern. Was schade war, wir haben Samstag, Samstag sind wir schon mal zum Stadion und haben dort dieses Museum besucht, also so wie das Bayern ja auch hat. Das ist ja ähnlich bei Turin. Ich habe leider im Vorhinein, weil ich da immer mich so ein bisschen schwer tue, wenn alles nur auf Englisch ist, ich habe halt keine Stadionführung im Internet gebucht und dachte, das können wir noch vor Ort. Ja, und das konnten wir leider nicht. Es war nichts zu machen, selbst mein Nurhold da und aus Deutschland und so. Es half nichts. Wir sind also leider nicht in die Stadionführung gekommen. Und die haben die halt so angeboten, dass man wohl auch so Audio Guides gekriegt hätte. Also mit der entsprechenden Sprache. Und ja, ich fürchte, ich muss da dann nochmal hin. Weil das hätte ich schon gerne gemacht.
Gibt es dann eigentlich einen bestimmten Grund, warum Turin nur wegen der Nähe? Oder ist da eine spezielle Beziehung dadurch ja auch vorhin, als es um die Zuneigung zu anderen Mannschaften als dem FC Bayern ging, auch erwähnt, dass du nächste Woche zum Spiel noch was vorhast? Gibt es zu Turin eine spezielle Beziehung?
Also ich bin einfach Turin-Fan in Italien, also von Juve schon ganz lange. Es sind ja auch viele Nationalspieler, die ich einfach gut finde bei Turin. Also Cillini und früher eben Samprata und Cannavara und so. Es ist halt Juve, wobei ich sagen muss, das passt natürlich jetzt auch nicht. Ich finde es auch schon beeindruckend, was Neapel macht und finde Neapel auch gut. Das liegt aber dann auch tatsächlich daran, weil mein Vater aus der Nähe von Neapel kommt. Ich bin so Juve-Fan und mit nächster Woche meinte ich einfach – und da kommen wir jetzt wieder zu den Geschichten, die mich einfach auch beim Fußball interessieren, wo ich dann eben manchmal auch eine nicht mehrheitsfähige Meinung habe – ich habe mich sehr, sehr, sehr darüber geärgert, wie Bayern mit Mandzukic am Schluss umgegangen ist. Ich war beim HSV-Spiel in der Liga – ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das letzte oder vorletzte Liga-Spiel war – wo er nicht eingesetzt wurde. Es hat mich maßlos geärgert, wie man verhindert hat, aus meiner Sicht, dass er Torschützenkönig wird. Ich fand das unmöglich. Und was ich mit nächster Woche gemeint habe, mein größter Wunsch – also mir ist schon klar, dass Bayern gegen Juve weiterkommt, aber mein größter Wunsch ist wirklich, dass Mandzukic ein Tor schießt, ein Tor für Pep Guardiola. Also er muss unbedingt treffen, das wünsche ich mir aus ganzem, ganzem Herzen. Das würde ich ihm so, so gönnen. Und ich fand es sehr schade, dass er im Hinspiel eher übermotiviert war und ich froh sein kann, dass er keinen Rot gekriegt hat. Ich hoffe, dass er am Mittwoch seine Nerven im Griff hat und ja, für mich ein Tor schießt. Das wäre wörtlich.
Womit auch klar wäre, dass wir dieses Tribünengespräch jetzt aber auch wirklich schnell veröffentlichen müssen.
Nein, weil dann auch mein Wunsch in Erfüllung gegangen ist oder nicht. Aber das sind so Sachen, die stören mich. Und wenn sie dann so kommen, finde ich sie dann einfach auch toll. Es gibt ja dann so Geschichten, wie sie der Fußball schreibt. Wenn dann irgendwie ein ehemaliger Spieler genau bei dem Verein dann ein Tor schießt oder so. Solche Sachen finde ich dann einfach irgendwie auch nett. Wenn sie nicht gerade gegen meinen Club sind.
Du bist halt einfach ein Fußballfan, durch und durch.
Ja, und ich finde es auch übrigens toll. Ich bin mal gespannt, was Samstag jetzt passiert. Ich finde es auch toll, wenn Spieler von denen, wenn sie zu ihrer Stätte zurückkehren und dann einfach da vorher ein gutes Standing hatten und dann auch wirklich super begrüßt werden. Also ich glaube, Ulrich ist so ein Fall, also als der mit Hamburg – ne, mit Wolfsburg war er glaube ich damals da. Ich weiß gar nicht genau, wo er auch vorgeschossen hat. Wo dann die Fans trotzdem gut reagiert haben. Und ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt und wünsche mir einfach auch, dass sie Pizarro super empfangen, weil Pizarro ist einfach, das finde ich ganz, ganz toll.
Ich glaube, davon kann man ausgehen, ja.
Schauen wir mal, ob das Spieltraining abgebrochen ist. Aber jetzt rutschen wir gerade von einem Tribünengespräch in eine Schlusskonferenz rein.
Entschuldigung?
Ne, ne, du, alles gut. Wir mögen halt den Fußball und reden gern drüber.
Genau.
Ja Pina, gibt es denn noch irgendwas, was du gerne noch loswerden wollen würdest? Wir haben dich ganz schön ausgepresst, finde ich.
Ja, ich habe ja natürlich auch viel geredet, von mir aus. Ich habe euch ja kaum fragen lassen.
So sollte es ja sein.
Ja, durchaus. Wäre schlimm, wenn es anders um gewesen wäre.
Also ich glaube, es ist schon rausgekommen, dass ich eben zumindest in früherer Zeit einfach ganz, ganz viel in Bewegung gesetzt habe, um irgendwie das zu erreichen und zu schaffen, was ich irgendwie machen möchte. Und ja, das kann ich nur jedem anderen irgendwie empfehlen, so Mut zu haben, auch wenn nicht alles immer glatt geht. Ich finde es jetzt so ein bisschen schade, dass ich so viel zu tun habe. Und naja, gut, ich meine, man ist ja auch irgendwie keine 25 oder 30 mehr. Zumindest ich nicht. Ich merke einfach auch, ich kann einfach auch nicht mehr so viel unterwegs sein. Also wenn man dann arbeitet. Also ein bisschen schade finde ich das. Aber es hat halt irgendwie so alles seine Zeit. Und ja, jetzt bin ich halt doch eher, ich sage jetzt mal, der normale Fußballkonsument geworden. Und ich kenne auch längst, also am Anfang habe ich mir immer vorgenommen, jeden neuen Kopfhörerplatz auch kennenzulernen. Da bin ich mittlerweile schon weit von entfernt. Ich drücke jetzt dann immer so die Daumen, dass bestimmte Leute nicht absteigen oder so, damit ich sie dann weiter in Hamburg auch dann mal sehen kann. Also, dass sie halt hier hinkommen.
Ja, so hat halt alles seine Zeit. Aber definitiv warst du sicher auch ein Bestandteil, dass sich für Sehbehinderte in Stadion viel verändert hat. Das ist jetzt, glaube ich, auch rausgekommen. Und einfach eine wahnsinnig interessante Fernbiografie. Ich bin neidisch auf ganz viele Erfahrungen, die du gemacht hast. Und habe mich sehr gefreut, dass du dir so ausführlich Zeit genommen hast für dieses Tribünengespräch.
Ja, vielen Dank, dass sich das einfach mal jemand, oder sogar zwei Leute und dann vielleicht auch noch draußen Hörer, sich Zeit nehmen und nicht einfach so viel erzählen konnte und durfte.
Hat mir sehr gut gefallen. Und ich bin sicher auch unseren Hörern. Und wir werden große Freude daran haben, das Feedback dann eigentlich weiterzuleiten.
Genau, exakt. Ja, in diesem Sinne vielen Dank für ein sehr interessantes Tribünengespräch. Ich hoffe sehr, dass es den Hörern auch gefallen hat. Mir persönlich hat es sehr gefallen, dass ich es zu zweit moderieren durfte.
Der Zaunpfahl ist kaum zu übersehen.
Genau, der akustische Zaunpfahl. Und gerne auch liebe Hörer da draußen, Ed Helmi. Man kann ihm auch bei Twitter schreiben und einfach fragen, hey, wann moderierst du denn nochmal? Hey, mir fehlt deine Stimme. Das sind so SMS, die schicke ich ihm auch gerne mal nachts. Du fehlt mir. Naja, mir hat es Spaß gemacht.
Mir auch, Max.
Dann sind wir uns alle einig. Sehr schön. Liebe Hörer, danke, dass ihr diese Folge gehört habt. Wenn ihr Feedback habt, schickt es uns gerne. Wir leiten das alles auch sehr gerne weiter an Pina. Pina, dir nochmal ganz herzlichen Dank. Würde mich sehr freuen, wenn wir uns vielleicht irgendwann mal treffen. Sag einfach mal Bescheid, wenn du in der Nähe bist. Und ich mache es wie zu versa.
Änderspiel.
Da könnte sich vielleicht sogar tatsächlich was ergeben.
Ja, werde ich auf jeden Fall vorher dir nochmal Bescheid sagen. Da habe ich dann ja meinen internen Familienkrieg. Sehr gut. Mein Mann hofft auf sein Geburtstagsgeschenk und ich hoffe, dass es vermasselt wird.
Ui, da bin ich gespannt. Ja, melde dich. Ich bin da beruflich wahrscheinlich, aber da kriegen wir vielleicht was hin. Das würde mich freuen. Da haben wir schon einen Termin am Horizont. Liebe Hörer, danke fürs Hören. Liebe Pina, danke fürs Mitmachen. Lieber Frank, danke, dass es dich gibt. Und in diesem Sinne, bis zum nächsten Tribünengespräch, wahrscheinlich dann im vierten Quartal 2017. Bis dahin, euch eine gute Zeit. Hört schön brav die Schlusskonferenz. Und bis dahin, macht's gut.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.